well hello again to be honest i sort of
feel like one of those ridiculous
weather forecasters standing on the dock
as a hurricane whips through
yes economic numbers are bad yes it's
likely to get worse before it gets
better
at this point the likelihood we're
headed into a recession is basically a
given
why aren't we there already because a
recession is generally described as a
period
of two consecutive quarters when gdp
goes down
simply put too little time has passed to
make it official there have been 33
recessions in the u.s
since 1854 with four occurring after
1980 so
while they're not a whole lot of fun
they are a pretty
normal part of the business cycle but
lately you may have heard another
word floating around depression
okay okay okay before we start freaking
out let's get a clear
picture on what a depression actually
looks like and see
what history has to teach us about
softening the blow
[Music]
let's start with a textbook definition
of what an economic depression
is atricia there actually isn't one
the national bureau of economic research
is responsible for officially declaring
the start or stop of a recession
but neither they nor any other agency
declares a depression
it's just considered a longer more
dramatic form of recession
how long and how dramatic depends on who
you ask
but one popular definition requires a
drop in gdp
of over 10 or duration longer than two
years to really be called a depression
there are some pretty striking
similarities between the 1930s and 2020.
for example at the peak of the great
depression unemployment rates hovered
around 24.9 percent
and those who kept their jobs saw their
salaries cut
and hours reduced as of late may
unemployment in the u.s
is hovering close to 28 percent
according to the u6 rate
covering the broadest definition of
unemployment there's also a clear uptick
in behaviors linked with
self-sufficiency
you don't have to scroll far to see a
picture of a home-baked bread or
newly planted veggie garden philip is
pickling everything inside and i feel i
have
finally achieved the level of sodo
sensei
my meemaw learned the same lessons from
the great depression
she was famous for her budget stretching
surprise casseroles that let nothing go
to waste
but unlike in my house she purposefully
never had
fresh bread always frozen since there
was no risk of it going to waste
didn't seem to slow her down though she
lived at the ripe old age of 99.
on the eve of world war ii many feared
our nation would be plunged into a
second deeper financial crisis but
instead
the following decades turned out to be
an era of unprecedented prosperity
how was that achieved first government
spending
president roosevelt's new deal used
federal funds to put
millions of unemployed people back to
work building the nation's
bridges roads parks and cities and
subsidized home
ownership through the creation of the
federal housing administration
and in order to meet the needs of the
war effort the government bought
vast amounts of military supplies from
private companies
and heavily invested in domestic
manufacturing
this double injection of funds from the
government is
widely credited with lessening the
length and severity of the great
depression
upon returning from the war millions of
service members utilize the gi bill to
attend college
helping to essentially create a true
middle class in america
compared to these massive projects the
cares act while a necessary first step
is only a fraction of what could be done
in the future
second devaluing our currency yes you
heard that right
weird as it may sound devaluing the
dollar played a
big role in getting us out of the last
mess
by breaking the strict tie of dollars to
gold
the government could freely print loads
of new dollars that were worth less
between 1933 and 1937 the money supply
increased 42 percent in his book
lords of finance leak ahmed observed
most economists now agree
90 of the reason the u.s got out of the
great depression
was the break with gold we've already
begun the devaluing process in response
to the pandemic by the fed
creating hundreds of billions of new
dollars in march
thus lowering the value of the dollar
why does this help
simply put a country with a weaker
currency will be more competitive in
global markets
though there are downsides like ticking
off your trading partners
many countries have recently taken issue
with china manipulating their currency
to gain a trade advantage
but if you do this too much you risk
creating hyperinflation
though experts uniformly agree we're
nowhere close to that happening
in the u.s a third factor in turning the
tide of the depression was
technological and business innovation
even in the
depths of a financial crisis new
innovators emerge
sort of like new seedlings sprouting
after a forest fire
obviously this is no justification for
the destruction kovit is wreaking but
historically temporary downturns have
accelerated breakthroughs the period
between 1929
and 1941 is widely considered the most
technologically progressive of the 20th
century
we might look back at this as a time
when remote learning and
telecommunications took
a huge leap forward a fourth strategy
was one not used by
government agencies or big business but
ordinary citizens
thriftiness i think it's best summed up
in the depression era mantra
use it up wear it out make do or do
without
this is a stark contrast to our modern
first world throwaway culture of
replacing cars
phones and computers every couple of
years in the 30s blue and white collar
families alike kept community thrift
gardens whenever possible they mended
their own clothing long before
considering buying something new
and opted to play card and board games
over more expensive entertainment
and for those unable to make ends meet
the use of government welfare programs
became so
normalized that much of the social
stigma fell away
things might feel really grim right now
but there is power to change the course
of the future
and it lies in the hands of governments
companies
and even individual citizens only time
will tell
how we'll look on the other side of this
but history shows
us that we get to play some part in how
the story ends
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
you